I I just thought they were my sisters
right and you know it was cool for me to
give my unsolicited advice
I watched it back I would like the nosy
bigmouth
little sister who was offering advice to
benefit sisters lives like that was I
learned a lot about myself I had to make
some changes
well my relationship with my sisters
definitely changed after that because I
worked on their last nerves I worked on
their nerves because it was different
because giving your sisters advice in
private is definitely different than
giving your sister's advice on
television and it's not like I did it
purposefully it was just that these are
my sisters and this is the problem and
this is who I am
I always knew who I was you know I think
the difference now is that you know I
realize that sometimes I can come across
as if I'm trying to hurt somebody's
feelings when it's just I'm passionate
about the things that you know I talk
about you know and I care about and it's
just that it comes across one way and I
mean something else so I had to really
scale back and only give my opinion when
I'm asked cuz I feel like if you ask me
y'all ready no I'm going to tell it like
it is
[Music]